david geary was a 30 year old student
studying for a phd in computer science
at columbia university in new york
last night just before midnight gary was
walking through morningside park right
next to columbia's campus that's when
out of nowhere a man knifed him in the
stomach
geary collapsed and died a short time
later
then gary's killer knifed a 27 year old
italian tourist who had arrived in new
york just days earlier
according to a witness the tourists
yelled why why help me
the witness said the suspect was quote
ecstatic and howling with glee as he
repeatedly plunged the knife into his
unsuspecting victim
a few minutes later the killer
threatened another man with a knife
before cops finally arrested him
authorities identified the killer as
vincent pinckney a member of the gang
everybody killers
he was out on parole at the time of the
last night stabbing spray he has 11
arrests dating back nearly a decade
in 2015 pickney was convicted of gang
assault for repeatedly slashing a man in
the face
none of it was enough to keep him behind
bars so last night he headed to
morningside park the same park where
exactly almost two years ago three thugs
ambushed and murdered a first-year
barnard college student as she was
looking down at her cell phone
after a year and a half of defunding the
police and building monuments to george
floyd morningside park hasn't gotten any
safer
think about the implications of that
authorities can't even secure a park a
few steps away from one of the most
well-known universities in the world
if it's dangerous there it's dangerous
everywhere
the new york of the early 1990s is back
and it's not just new york many of this
country's biggest cities are going
backwards in the same way the city of
philadelphia my hometown just set a new
all-time record for murders
the
513 murders in philadelphia this year
breaks the city's previous record of 500
which was set in 1990
just days ago a 14 year old boy in the
city was shot 18 times
samir jefferson a 14 year old thomas a
edison high school freshman was waiting
for the bus near wyoming and rising sun
in feltonville monday afternoon around 3
30 p.m when police say two people got
out of a car and chased him firing off
about 35 rounds jefferson was hit 18
times and ran a block before collapsing
the rite aid at the busy intersection
was covered in bullet holes tuesday this
is happening all over the country
louisville kentucky tucson arizona and
columbus ohio have also set new murder
records this year and with just under
two months left in 2021 indianapolis has
broken its criminal homicide record for
the second consecutive year
cook county which includes chicago just
surpassed a thousand homicides for the
first time since 1994. i've never seen a
thousand homicides for the whole you
know 17 years have been in this office
cook county's chief medical examiner on
the report released by her office with
some very alarming statistics 1009
homicides to date which is the highest
in 27 years
156 children or teenaged victims 96
percent of the victims african-american
or latino and a 40 percent increase in
homicide since 2019.
several of those homicides have cut down
students at the university of chicago
which was once a hotbed for the defund
the police movement and by the way an
increasing number of these crimes are
committed by juveniles who usually
aren't charged as adults
remember the two teenage girls in
washington dc who carjacked and killed
an uber each driver in broad daylight
they were both sentenced to juvenile
detention until they're 21.
they're getting just a handful of years
in prison for murdering somebody
gangs recognize this and they're
encouraging more kids to get involved in
the criminal activity in chicago
authorities just arrested a preteen for
carjacking
the vehicular hijacking task force
arrested an 11 year old
on november 26 for felony aggravated
vehicular hijacking
let me say that again because that
shocks the conscience
our task force rested and arrested an 11
year old
meanwhile in st louis shots rang out as
the mayor was talking about gun
prevention
isn't that wonderful my son and i fall
asleep to the lullaby of gunshots in the
distance every night because i'm the
first mayor in over 20 years to be born
raised and still live in north st louis
and it's unfortunate you know yes i
heard it but i didn't flinch
because
you know i'm i guess i
it's a part of my life now what's the
common thread linking all these cities
look at who's funding the prosecutors in
st louis circuit attorney kim gardner's
campaign took more than 200 grand from a
group backed by the billionaire george
soros
soros knew what he was paying for
gardner was open about her desire to
stop prosecuting crimes two years ago
garner declared quote
we have to tear down the system the
system's going to do what it's going to
do
and that is to cause harm the system is
caused harm by what is called mass
incarceration
gardeners followed through on that
promise data from 2019 show that gardner
issued warrants for just 23 of the cases
brought by the saint louis police
soros has also funded d.a larry krasner
in philadelphia kim fox chicago and
george gascon in l.a
there are no campaign finance limits on
these local elections so soros is free
to spend millions on them and he's not
the only one doing it in san francisco
some of the richest people in the
country got chessa boudine elected d.a
a pack supporting boudin's campaign
received a million bucks from the wife
of dustin moskowitz who co-founded
facebook
the so-called real justice pack supports
prosecutors like boudin across the
country who want to ignore the laws on
the books
one big supporter of the group is patty
quillen the wife of netflix is chairman
reed hastings
boudin's campaign also directly received
tens of thousands of dollars from
caitlyn kreiger the wife of instagram's
co-founder
as a result san francisco looks like
this
the sounds and sights of union square
are not as pretty today as they usually
are windows are boarded up at louis
vuitton crews replacing an entire door
at this eve saint laurent windows are
shattered at burberry with a hole still
left over on its door
wooden boards also covered the windows
at mermaids a witness captured the
moment people tried to break in when i
passed by or missed their group of
people i would say it's really around
100 people
and then after i passed them they just
started to try to
to get into hermes and they started
cracking the glass union square is often
the target of organized retail theft and
looting if you're wondering how to stop
all this and get crime under control it
helps to remember where we've been
before take a look at this chart it
shows how police budgets have changed
since 1994. the last time crime was
completely out of control in this
country
those budgets have gone up 46 percent in
the last two decades
now look at the effect on homicide rates
they dropped 32 percent per capita
in other words increasing police budgets
helps that's proven
but it's not the full solution cops can
only do so much you also need
prosecutors to punish criminals
one researcher at the university of
texas found that about 25 percent of the
1990s crime drop can be linked to
increased incarceration which only
happens when prosecutors get convictions
that's not happening nearly as much as
it should be
so how can we fix this problem and save
our cities hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else